alain delon gérard depardieu ou encore
sean connery des rencontres surprenantes
au détour de la rue du général-de-gaulle
à poissy derrière les vitrines de deux
brasseries le montant d'or et le
batignolles une sélection du photographe
franck ce tron met en scène de
nombreuses personnalités il ya des
histoires sur chaque image
il ya des rencontres sont des vraies
rencontres et femmes michaël youn il l'a
très bien compris en faisant justement
la direction artistique parce qu'elle
met en avant justement tout ce côté a
fait que j'ai pu avoir par rapport à
l'image par rapport à des moments par
rapport à des à des personnes
visuellement il fallait quelque chose
qui se voit même de loin avec des
grandes faces des grandes vitrines comme
ça il fallait quelque chose qui se voit
donc c'est pour ça le choix de
de ses toiles de ceux des grandes toiles
une sélection parmi l'exposition lumière
et 7e art mise en place par le duo en
2018 à l'espace noir et des
clayes-sous-bois environ un tiers de son
contenu a été exposé à nouveau pour
redonner vie à une rue habituellement
animées hors périodes de confinement je
suis partie mois du principe où la
culture a été quelque chose qui qui
devait être accessible à vraiment à tout
le monde que c'est aussi à un art de
vivre c'est un moyen de s'exprimer
après tout c'est à nous d'amener l'art
pour que les gens voient les gens qu'est
ce qu'ils vont faire ils vont aller se
promener ils vont aller faire leurs
courses
y'a pas de divertissement alors sur le
chemin de leur course et bien ses amours
d'amener l'art et de leur proposer des
choses pour les divertir et
leur donner le sourire le choix de ces
deux emplacements n'est pas le fruit du
hasard
à une extrémité l'autre de la rue les
grandes vitrines coffret les restaurants
permettait de mettre en valeur les
toiles l'idée d'avoir des photos qui
somme toute noire et blanche me
paraissent plus en plus plus plus un
pack d'avoir un rideau noir devant la
vitrine pour ce qui est des expositions
borloo a toujours fait ça change tous
les mois ce soit de la photo que ce soit
de la peinture du dessin
au total ce sont quatorze portraits de
célébrités exposée pour donner via la
rue en attendant que les restaurants
cuisse peut être ré ouvrir leurs portes
le 20 janvier prochain